- [Mark] All right.
Amber, welcome back.
- Hi well thank you for having me.
- [Mark] It's been a
couple of months, right?
- Yeah it's been a few months.
- [Mark] So what's, what's been going on?
- Well still, still vague,
but a lot of things have changed.
Um, after seeing the other,
the other people on the shows.
I learned a lot, that my story is not that
my life wasn't that bad, you know.
I just made bad choices.
So now I have another thought process now.
As, at the time it was a
kid, it was the worst thing.
But now as an adult and you
hear all these other stories,
I'm just like, thank God, thankful.
- [Mark] I mean, there's a
lot of girls that worked Fig,
do you think they all are out there
and maybe no one's really aware
of other people's history?
- I think that 95 or 90
percent of the women out there
on Fig are victims of childhood trauma.
And no one has a clue.
I was talking to a couple
other girls and they were like,
"I was in the same thing, but
it was still dah, dah, dah."
I was like, "Whoa!"
Okay. So it made me
think like, okay, Amber
if your life wasn't that
bad, get it together.
Stop messing around.
So, I have toned down my working.
I probably even see only 25%,
25% of the people that was seen before.
I don't like it any longer.
I see the badness in it,
the disrespect things how...
There's other ways to make money.
There's other ways to get by.
I learned that from watching the videos
and by talking to them,
the girls, a lot of people
a lot of my friends were like,
"Whoa! I didn't know that
that's what happened to you."
Can you tell me some more about it?
So as I tell them more, they're like, yeah
I had that choice.
I had to make that choice too.
Family, survival or not to survive.
So I got like a lot of like okay,
pat on the backs for making
decisions to survive.
But then I read the comments
and a lot of the comments were like
no one has right to do that to you.
No one should do that to you.
No one should do that to anyone.
But I didn't know,
I thought it was just part
of the work, part of the job.
So now I got get together.
I gotta make changes.
I want to be the best person I could be.
Not the best working girl I could be.
And that's where I was
at three months ago.
Work, work, work, work.
Now it's steady, steady,
steady, steady, steady.
- [Mark] So you're working less?
- Way less.
I'm afraid to work.
Hearing some of these girls story
about what happened to them on dates,
mine's was nothing.
Like I said, I didn't get hurt.
Some of these girls
when you see the tapes,
they're permanently disfigured.
I got a couple of scratches,
a couple of battle wounds
but I got to get out of here
before I become permanently disfigured.
I lost the tooth the other day on a date.
And I was like, okay, this is not okay.
- [Mark] What happened?
- I was with a man that
was has been a vet,
been in Afghanistan.
Some other people were
fighting outside of the room
and then like he had a flashback,
I guess PTSD.
And he punched me, elbowed me
and we're at that point,
we both were trying to get out
of the room at the same time
because whatever he saw I felt was coming
and he knew it was coming.
So it was like, let's get out of here.
But yeah, I'm missing a tooth now.
That's it for me?
(chuckles) I'm done.
Now that I could check Lennar,
I'm finished.
So I'm going back to school,
online classes as the moment.
- [Mark] Good for you.
- I'm going back sooner
than I thought.(chuckles)
Way sooner.
- [Mark] I hear, I hear
so many girls tell,
these horrific stories of things
that have happened to them
while they're working on the street,
and my reaction, I haven't said anything,
but my my thoughts are
like, well, that, that's a
that's a sign that you
should never ever do that.
It's too dangerous.
- Right. Red flag.
- [Mark] But they all go back.
- It's a red flag.
- [Mark] That's a red flag.(chuckles)
- Red flag.
- [Mark] It's, it's, it's
it's part of a clear sign
as anything that you
should not do that again.
- You're right.
- [Mark] But these girls do
it for years and decades.
- Well, sometimes it's an endless cycle.
Okay, you stop doing it now,
what are you gonna do?
How are you gonna eat?
We are you gonna go?
Some people, this is for
some women and some men.
This is the only thing they know
to get to the next stage in their life.
Whether it be eating, it's
a survival, you know, it's
it's our three survival skills as humans.
So it's hard.
There's no resources.
And when you're trapped
in this, this life,
you don't know how to even get out of it.
You don't know if you
should, what should you say?
Who should you go to?
There's no resources at all.
So you stay, just stay with what they know
because they know that,
they do this they'll get fed.
- [Mark] And they get
addicted to the fast money.
- A lot, it's it's addicting because I, I
the first time I said I'm done,
which was just a few years ago.
I cried.
I cried like I, I lost my parents.
Because here it is now,
Now what do I do?
I'm bored.
What do I do?
I'm here.
I'm like thinking about what, where,
what I could be doing at this time of day,
how much money I might have?
And I don't have it.
It was like losing a family member.
The decision to step off of the track.
It's addicting.
If this becomes your life, you're family.
10, 15 years out here is the same as
building a relationship in a family.
You have to wa...
You lose your kid or you
lose a 15 year old something.
You're feeling it.
And I definitely feel,
felt it that last time.
But this time I got to plan,
got to make some plans.
Something different,
positive thinking motivates.
Just talk to someone, anyone.
- [Mark] You need to
replace it with something.
- You have to, because you're
just there, like boredom.
Now what do I do?
Gets thinking in your
head and your best think
is what got you in the
situation you're in.
So you should maybe fall out.
- [Mark] I think there
are very few addicts
or alcoholics or whatever the
gambling addicts, you name it,
who just decided to quit and that was it.
They found something else
that fills that void.
- Yeah. They find other
things to fill that void
or they just stop using,
but they still have that
mindset of an addict
and they take the next thing
and they do it just the
same way as they did using.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And hopefully you'll
find something healthier.
- Well, I'm going to school.
So I'm hoping that the
books and the studying.
- [Mark] (chuckles) That's very good.
- And the, you know focusing
on my grades and my tests.
That's how it's gonna,
pass that time that boring,
that boredom that I have.
So yeah, school.
- [Mark] It's almost, it's almost, I mean
because I've heard so many
stories with addicts with
with sex workers, with gang
members, all kinds of people,
it's almost like the perception, the idea
that the street life is
cool or doing drugs is cool.
- Right.
- [Mark] Or being in a gang is cool.
It's almost like that.
That's the thinking that needs to change.
- Right.
- [Mark] And something like,
being responsible a human
being that's that's upstanding
and has a job and went
to school and got an
achieve something that needs
to be seen as cool again.
- Well.
- [Mark] As it did, maybe back
in the sixties or fifties.
- Yeah. Well, see you're going
back fifties and sixties.
A lot of things are gonna change.
We all know why they're gonna change.
We, if you don't know anything
if that's what your, your grandma did
or that's what your grandpa did,
or your mom did your dad did,
gang bang or do drugs or street life.
It does seem like fun, when
you're outside looking in,
it doesn't seem like cool.
She leaves, she comes back with $600
but you have no idea what
it took to get that $600.
And I'm not going to tell you
that I had to do this and that
or that I had to, you know
the worst case scenario had happened.
I'm going to glamorize it.
Like, Hey, I got this money.
Let's get high, or this is whatever shop
but you don't have any idea
what that took to get it.
Okay everything drinking, gang banging,
working in the streets
it's glorified from
television, rap, magazines.
It's it's, it's the shit.
- [Mark] Is it made cool?
- It's what you do.
You use drugs.
You're smoke some weed.
You're a gang member.
You rap and write.
You know, you're, you're a street worker,
you get that money.
That's what we were taught.
That's what television shows us.
That's what society shows us.
But once you get into that lifestyle,
you're like, whoa.
I didn't know that I
was going to get raped
when I start working the streets.
I didn't know that, no one told me that.
They just said, Oh, get that money,
have fun, you know.
No one said, "Hey girl more likely
you're going to be getting raped."
If someone with told me that
when I was 16 years old,
oh no, I would have found
another job, something different.
But I didn't know.
I was thinking it was cool
because my friend at
the time she would leave
and come back one hundreds.
You're going 30 minutes, 600,
oh yeah, I could do that.
I could learn it like that.
And that's what you do.
Gang banging, oh man, I got this lower,
I got these bitches,
I got, you know I got what I want.
But you didn't know,
he had to knock off a couple of people.
You know he has to go and
do harmful, harm to people.
He has to sell drugs and
put drugs in neighborhood.
That's how he got that.
So we're just lied too.
It's all misconception.
- [Mark] Yeah. It's
almost like our perception
of what is cool and needs to change.
- Yeah.
A lot definitely has to change.
A lot of things have to change
- [Mark] Because there's so what I see is,
there's so many self-destructive
paths that are seen as cool
and you've got a whole
support system saying,
"yeah that's cool."
And it's not
- Right. So its hard to
stand up and say uh uh.
- [Mark] It takes you down.
- You go from looking
like a beauty queen to,
to a delphine, in a
matter of what, 90 days?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Not cool.
That's what we need to show,
like this site or channel.
That's what the channel shows.
Guess what, all of these
people were once like you,
once like and TV world out there.
But this is what's going to happen.
It's not can happen, this
is what's going to happen.
If you take these routes, this
route, make these choices.
It's not if, it's gonna, it's gonna happen
you're gonna lose your life out here.
You're gonna get stabbed
or going to get raped or
you're getting robbed.
It is going to happen.
Now had I seen a magazine
called "it's going to happen."
A lot of things were cheaper,
like different, you know.
A lot of things would be different,
even if you took them, they had what,
scared straight for kids that
have had criminal issues.
They took them to prison
and they incarcerate.
We need to start doing that
with some of these.
- [Mark] Well that's what
this channel kinda does.
- You know, first graders.
Cause now you got to start
way younger than you started
when I was a kid we
started when I was nine.
By nine I'm pregnant already twice.
- [Mark] Now tell, tell
me a young kid watching
a bunch of these videos
and seeing the end result.
- Yeah, this is the end.
- [Mark] I mean, if you can't
put two and two together,
then, then you're you're.(chuckles)
- Wait till you, wait till
you do that next update
with the death date on there.
You know, this is of their death.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You know, if anything happens.
- [Mark] I think I got
one of those coming up.
Just shot at.
- Wow.
- [Mark] He just died across
the street from my studio.
How much should we get?
I think the rumor, the rumor is he's dead
but we're trying to confirm.
- [Amber] Confirm it.
- [Mark] Good friend of mine.
All right Amber, thank you
so much for coming in again.
- Thank you for having me again.
- [Mark] And good luck
is where you're going.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] It sounds great.
- Thanks.
- [Mark] Thank you.
- Goodbye.
I want to come back after
school like next semester.
- [Mark] I wish I could do
like 300 videos like yours.
(Amber chuckles)